why does all this come from where is this
impudent manner of speaking from the standpoint of one’s
own exclusivity,
infallibility, and everything, God
[music]
is possible in general in nature, the entry of
Russian troops into Ukraine
or we will not continue to fight
for equality of rights, this applies to all
states, this does not mean at all that we
are going to  waving a saber and
sending in troops is complete nonsense there is
nothing like this and cannot be the main
administrative buildings in Crimea are
patrolled by Russian troops so far there have been
no skirmishes with the Ukrainian
military but a message of
confrontation comes from different places
unidentified armed men in
camouflage guard the building of the local
parliament in the capitals of Crimea  simferopol
you came to the referendum and made a
decision thanks to your decision
sevastopol and crimea returned to their
home in the house of our mother russia
crimea spore super important to the forces and the Crimean
Tatars leaves the apparatus steve from the
territory of the supreme council of crimea in
simferopol
[applause  ents]
and
a woman 20 the plane you have in the hall
are little men they take control of the
admin will it be good comfort screeching partly on the
Ukrainian soldier and take over the
Russian ensign and
[music]
Russian soldiers me it was the local
self-defense forces
behind the Crimean self-defense forces of
course  our servicemen got up
this is a fact we are not selling they hid
our armed forces frankly
blockaded the armed forces of ukraine
stationed in the crimea you
restored the historical
justice that was violated
in soviet times when crimea and
sevastopol were illegally
torn away from russian even according to soviet laws
Federation On March 3,
peaceful women's protests begin. For a
week, thousands of people go out on trained
roads with posters. Crimea is Ukraine.
We are with Ukraine.
On March 9, a rally in honor of Taras's birthday
for grandmothers.
they are all nonsense this is all
there is no Russian units in the east of Ukraine
there are no
special services there are no instructors these are
all local citizens
Russian subdivisions will give whom you
hope another 5 company tactical groups
are equipped with armored vehicles
paraffin for two dozen artists 20
is to find armored vehicles terrorists
paraffin to olenevka also
fixed in the water of Russia having left a
rough installation 200 to the house you loved
150 thousand Russian
really if our detachment had not
come to the donbass and would not have become the core of
resistance the core of the Russian spring in the
donbass then  most likely, without this core
,
both armored vehicles and not
artillery systems were suppressed, etc. and so on in the
modern world, people who are
fighting and who consider this fight
fair for themselves from their point of view
will find weapons
[music]
mon-50 200 requis works 50  also calling in
this n 2 spades y  we are our eyebrows are
also on the tour of them we are cooking the
action so here is the indicated rick
so here is the army of russia sukhpai
2015 go to rock so yours are such miracle
ribbons
hoods
jet infantry flamethrower of the russian
federation for up to 1000 times everything and your
shelling of our  well, not
an RPG-7 with different nozzles with
carved nozzles, but I fought against the
backdrop of our Russian tank
[music]
so
there almost every day people die peacefully
for peaceful reasons and
here we really provide
humanitarian and other assistance  and support for the
people who live in this
territory,
but only so that they
are not completely crushed there, they are not eaten, it’s
ridiculous that they didn’t tear today to swim in 10 30
occupiers gave and in the outside can the
hall of the Kramatorsk static
missile system point-at shelling was here
for about 5 minutes an hour of evacuation  the peaceful population of the
greedy did not suffer in a place in the
Luhansk region, the view of Russian tan glare did not
end, but my whole  the infrastructure of the
region, you know, it is about the kingdom and the head of the
regional administration, cheerful sergey
gaida, invat, the attack, the gun was rich in the
archive of the kite, spitting is not a bottle of Vlasich, a
chance to, while our plans do not include the
occupation of Ukrainians, we are
not going to impose forces on anyone, Russia
has done everything to preserve
territorial integrity of ukraine,
why is it a view of 1 invented, well,
the hour has gone to work at the court, he does not let the respected
residents of the city of melitopol and the
melitopol region now our
main task is to adjust all the
mechanisms to the new reality,
now the issue of creating a
committee of people's deputies is being worked out,
this particular committee will deal with all
administrative issues on the
territory of Melitopol and the Melitopol
region, I propose to contact the head of the
Donetsk People's Republic
with consideration of
0 and Konstantin for the position of the head of the
city to the sea
, but our guys, soldiers and officers, show
courage and heroism,
do everything from them  it depends in order to
avoid losses among the civilian population of
Ukrainian cities,
just just a residential building we see a
pharmacy there was
access Russian invaders shelled Mariupol in the roughing
pile patiently one hundred
miles today has become a symbol of Ukrainian
spite to me screeds with coils of g glorious evil
mending the occupier bunnies the wound of the chain zma
come retribution
all the frosts of fish, then 17 popular among
quixotes, are worn on in Kharkov today,
Russian invaders fired on the morning of the
itch and sprat in the area of
\u200b\u200bthe place and the invaders cannot take the frontier in the Luhansk region, then
my civilian infrastructure will be shot down
just on the ears, our
minimal groups of
sprats were raked by special forces of missile strikes
in nature ipad  and
18 people have already left the bulk center with cream, 59 people have already departed from the channel,
59 people of purana, not
russia continues to fire makkalow
atmos with missiles, has already improved the words and houses
four people have looked five 3
manipura I
wish Putin to die as soon as possible
[applause]
people who lived on
certain  in the territories of modern
Ukraine, no one has ever asked about
how they themselves want to arrange their lives
in the basis of our policy freedom freedom of
choice for everyone to independently
determine their future and the future of their
children
you do
[music]